dos años después de que la catedral de
notre damme ardiera en llamas los
encargados de su restauración siguen
trabajando para rehabilitarla con motivo
de su aniversario el presidente manuel
macrón visitó el lugar por primera vez
desde el suceso para ver el progreso de
las obras en la catedral
estamos impresionados con lo que vemos
con el trabajo que se ha realizado en
dos años creo que todo el mundo se
acuerda hoy de donde estábamos hace dos
años de lo que sentimos de cómo se
sienten todos los católicos los
parisinos y todo el pueblo francés en
realidad
creo que aquí vemos que se ha hecho un
trabajo enorme en dos años
hasta el momento los técnicos se han
encargado de reforzar la estructura de
la catedral y la restauración no
empezará hasta este verano con el tiempo
en su contra durante la visita macrón
sostuvo su promesa de reabrir notredame
en 2024 para dar un soplo de esperanza a
los franceses en medio de la pandemia
muchos todavía tiene muy presente el
dolor y la ansiedad de aquel día con más
tensión y fox pictures para mí fue muy
conmovedor soy cristiana y mi yerno
también es portugués y es muy cristiano
nos quedamos en shock llegué a casa puse
la tele y pensé que estaban haciendo una
película mi yerno me llamó y los dos
lloramos
incluso si toma 10 años es mejor que
tome 10 años que se haga rápido y
colapse después y así es cuando hay más
daños en el patrimonio histórico que se
quedan prefiero eso al menos está
progresando podemos verlo
aunque más cron cumpla con su objetivo
de la catedral reabra en 2024 los
obreros ya han avisado que el trabajo no
estará finalizado este año hasta
devolverle el esplendor por completo a
la obra parisina